JENNY BROWN: Today,
we're wrapping up Next
and talking about confidential
computing and machine learning.
I'm Jenny, and welcome to "This
Week in Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
If you've been hanging out with
us for the past nine weeks,
we've worked on an actual ton
of content with Next OnAir.
It's been a lot of
fun, but it can also
be hard to keep track of all the
different topics we've covered.
That's why we've compiled a
full list of announcements
so you can review and get
more on all your favorites.
No matter how you want
to use Google Cloud,
your data is your data.
We're always looking
to improve security.
And now, we've announced
confidential computing.
This keeps your data
even more secure
by keeping data encrypted in
memory and away from the CPU.
We've recently launched
confidential VMs
and are now expanding
that security
to confidential GKE nodes.
Building ML and AI apps
can take a lot of work,
but there's more
tooling than ever
to help you capture
the power of ML.
Dale Markowitz,
applied AI engineer,
has put together a list
of helpful tools and tips
to how to spend more time on
your application and less time
on tweaking your models.
We love good documentation,
as it can help
make a hard project possible.
Code samples are always welcome.
And now, it's even
easier to use them,
thanks to interactive
documentation.
You can put in your
specific values,
and the code samples will update
to match exactly what you need.
And you can even
preview actual results.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list, check out
the link in the description.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us,
and we'll see it in the Cloud.